Da sind wir egoistisch genug.
Wir wollen unser Leben auch
fertig leben.
Wir sind vorausschauend genug,
so dass sich Julia nicht erst ...
... von uns trennen muss, wenn
wir hinfällig sind und sterben.
Das ist ein grosses Thema, und
man muss darüber sprechen.
Man muss es zum Thema machen,
solange noch alle miteinander ...
... darüber reden können. Denn
irgendwann sind die Eltern ...
... tot, und dann muss man
ganz plötzlich schauen, wie
es weitergehen soll.
Ich hoffe, wir haben den
Rucksack für Julia ...
... in den letzten 20 Jahren
gut gepackt.
Julia hat ein gutes Selbstwert-
gefühl, sie weiss, wer sie ist.
Sie weiss, welchen Weg sie
gehen will.
Ja, und sie hat meine
Telefonnummer!:-)
Es ist ein bisschen so,
wie bei einem kleinen
Vögelchen, das man findet.
Das päppelt man auf und
und zieht es gross.
Und irgendwann muss man
ans Fenster stehen ...
... und muss es fliegen lassen.
Genau, Papa. Wie ein Pferd,
das ausreitet, weil es ...
... weg will vom Bauernhof.
Ja Julia, das ist das Schöne,
wenn man auszieht, ...
... dass etwas Neues kommt!
Mich freut's und reut's, dass
Julia auszieht.
Es wird weniger Betrieb im
Haus sein.
Aber es freut mich, dass
sie flügge sind und ...
... selbstständig wohnen
und sich entwickeln können.
Jetzt muss ich auch Gas
geben, mit dem Kochen und so.
Ich habe auch ein eigenes
Leben, wo ich machen kann,
was ich will!
Sie ist einfach selbstständiger,
macht ihre Brötchen selbst ...
... oder räumt den Tisch
von sich aus ab.
Du kannst zum Tisch kommen.
Es wäre schön, wenn ich das
auch machen könnte.
Ich möchte auch so selbstständig
wie Remo sein.
Das will ich üben. Ich
möchte das, damit ...
... ich mehr Verantwortung
übernehmen kann.
Ich möchte, dass er mal
eine Pause macht.
Pause kann man machen,
wenn alles fertig ist.
Ach komm jetzt. Das
brauchst du jetzt.
Also ich zwinge dich nicht,
aber es tut dir gut.
Weisst du, für deine
Ausdauer.
Ich habe schon noch Ausdauer.
Bist du sicher?
Ja.
Ich gehe mal schauen,
ob die anderen so weit sind.
Okay, ich helfe dir!
Das Administrative, wie sie
zum Beispiel Anträge ...
... schreiben muss, dafür
gäbe es auch andere ...
... Menschen, die das können,
oder auch Institutionen.
Das würde die KESB, also
ein professioneller Beistand
übernehmen.